[Musique]
finalement ça se fasse pas lourd au
niveau de la vie des stars endroit
original où l'on parle de copies nous
sommes à paris au musée de la
contrefaçon
comme tous les jours une classe de
lycéens vient apprendre ici le sens d'un
mot un seul justement contrefaçon
c'est une chose très copiés
le consommateur
c'est un délit c'est la leçon et bien
apprises mais quand on parle de céder le
message semble plus difficile à faire
passer surtout depuis l'apparition des
graveurs sur le marché pour 1500 francs
en moyenne
tout le monde peut dupliquer ses cd et
devenir ainsi contrefacteurs on avait
des copains qui se gravent eux mêmes
leur cd non ça ne va pas tous mais
l'admiration pour moi il y en a quand on
revient facile sur pourquoi parce que
les autres sans trop cher cherchons mais
ça leur prend dans un cd qu'en sachant
qu'on peut l'avoir pour maffrand on va
pas l'écouter avis et vous avez
l'impression de commettre un délit quand
vous faites ça
pour nous c'est habituel peu de
personnes que l'on pense pas trop
personnel j'en fais mon affaire de vous
acheter un graveur un cd vierge et vous
il ya un copain cache l2 voilà voilà
heures après on passe un cd où elle nous
donne 10 francs pour la grave non pas
pour ceux qui m'ont surtout pour ceux
qui connaît pour être sûr qu'il ait pas
de nous sommes bien loin des mafias
asiatiques pourtant le délit est le même
les faussaires des cours de récré aurait
coûté à l'industrie du disque dans le
monde plus de 10 milliards de francs
en 99
mais il existe une autre forme de
piratage dont vincent est un digne
représentant
il prend ses idées dans les magasins
traditionnels mais jamais plus il ne
leur achètera un disque ça fait
longtemps que j'avais pas acheté de cds
dans un grand magasin comme ça ça fait
pas mal de temps et plusieurs mois
pourquoi bas parce que déjà d'ébullition
très très cher et en plus maintenant je
peux les télécharger gratuitement sur
internet
malgré que celui-là soit l'un des moins
chers du magasin ça reste toujours assez
cher vous allez le prendre sur internet
je voudrais je vais rentrer à la maison
et je pense que cela me plaît bien je
pense que je vais aller me vallet de
télécharger larmes de vincent le mp3 de
lettres et un chiffre qui font trembler
l'industrie du disque mp3
c'est un nouveau format de compression
il permet de faire passer de la musique
par internet
du coup les internautes s'organisent
s'échangent des musiques et pour se
rencontrer il dispose même d'un
supermarché virtuel nom de code napster
alors donc tout à l'heure on a vu dans
le magasin de disques de céline dion
donc j'avais le choix entre lâcheté ou
maintenant de télécharger via internet
grand saint michel qui s'appelle napster
c'est une bourse d'échangé international
de musique par exemple à l'heure
actuelle il ya une pub 1300 personnes
qui sont connectés et qui propose un
total de 106 1000 chansons disponibles
en téléchargement gratuitement bien sûr
donc là je vais taper dans la caisse
artistes l'artiste concerné donc en
l'occurrence céline dion j'ai plus d'une
centaine de réponses sur céline dion
savez du premier album au dernier album
qu'on trouve à l'heure actuelle en
magasin donc là je vais lancer le
téléchargement de cette chanson là il
sole coming back et quelques minutes
plus tard
[Musique]
dans le même temps vincent a fait
tourner son graveur résultats donc
maintenant qu'il est gravé et je le sors
de donc sage est gravé un titre de su
j'aurais pu graver tout l'album de
céline dion il aura fallu je télécharge
des autres chansons dont clan le clan
gens les charges et qu ensuite je vais
tester sur ma chaine hifi up sur le
disque plein et est ce que ça marche ça
devrait marcher
voilà pourquoi vincent on achète plus de
disque en magasin
coût de l'opération 10 francs le prix du
cd vierges
problème ces musiques échanger sur
internet ne paye pas les droits d'auteur
légale illégale
nous avons consulté un spécialiste
clairement il est dans l'illégalité
lorsqu'ils procèdent au téléchargement
on ne peut ignorer que ces musiques sont
protégés par le droit d'auteur
elles appartiennent à l'auteur et en ce
qui concerne la diffusion sûrement un
éditeur de musique et en conséquence
connaissant parfaitement cette situation
peu importe que l'on soit sur l'internet
peu importe qu'on utilise ce logiciel
magnifique de recherche d'informations
musicale soit mais trois il est clair
qu'il ya une infraction contrefaçon et
là ils encourent quoi deux ans de prison
et un million de francs d'amendé est ce
que vous savez ce que vous risquez en
faisant ça pas vraiment pas du tout même
à deux ans de prison et un million de
francs d'amendé quand même mais encore
faut-il attraper les gens qui
téléchargent et qui gravent d aider
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment de
commettre d'une certaine manière un vol
en faisant ça je persiste à dire que je
trouve que le prix d'un cd est beaucoup
trop chère par rapport à la part que
prend l'artiste aidé à part que prend la
maison de disques s'il y avait un juste
milieu que l'artiste gagner autant que
la maison de disque là
il faudrait encore réfléchir mais je
pense que ça changerait pas mal de
choses elle près du cdb serait pas de
moitié mais pas loin malgré la sanction
possible vous allez continuer ah oui
alors ça c'est sûr et certain
sans problème en la matière il est vrai
les condamnations sont plutôt rares
difficile pour le droit de rattraper une
technologie qui va toujours plus vite
pour autant peut-on parler de vide
juridique il n'y a pas de vide juridique
sur l'internet c'est plutôt l'enfer
pourquoi parce que la plupart des
oeuvres sont protégés par le droit
d'auteur mais n'ont pas forcément le
même statut regarder si on va sur le
site de france 2 et sur plus
particulièrement d'envoyé spécial
vous voyez on a des textes on a des
images
lorsqu'on utilise ce texte pas de
problème je peux en faire une copie le
rapatrier c'est possible je peux prendre
cette image et la rapatrier c'est
possible aussi c'est ce qu'on va appeler
la copie privée à usage non collectif
maintenant un enfant qui décide de faire
un exposé il va prendre ce même texte
parce qu'il parlait de envoyé spécial il
va mettre ça entre guillemets il va
citer et c'est possible parce qu'on a la
possibilité de faire une courte citation
pour les hommes par contre s'il veut
utiliser l'image ce n'est pas possible
il n'y a pas de course et citations en
matière d'image
allez comprendre comment voulez vous
condamnez les utilisateurs de ce type de
type quand vous même avocat vous dites
que c'est inextricable
j'ai pas dit ni strict alger dit que
c'était un des visites pédagogiques
il faudra bien évidemment harmoniser
c'est pour ça que je parlé d'enfer
il faudra une loi capable de mettre tout
le droit du numérique pour la protection
des oeuvres dans une situation homogène
mais cela peut pas dire que ce petit
trou juridique ce déficit de pédagogie
entraîne obligatoirement a droit à la
liberté de contrefaçon ça c'est à
tolérer est intolérable et déjà les
premiers films sont disponibles sur
internet
ces nouvelles technologies soulève de
nombreuses questions
faudra-t-il demain redéfinir la notion
de droits d'auteur la création est elle
vraiment en danger ou saura-t-elle
s'adapter comme elle l'a toujours fait
[Musique]